Claire Parker is an 18 year old
fun-loving teenager who lives with her
single mother in a small town in the U.S
she works night shifts at a local
department store and usually returns
home with her boyfriend Jimmy however
one day while she is waiting for him a
middle-aged random guy shows up in
Jimmy's truck the man introduces himself
as duke Desmond and claims that Jimmy
has sent him here to pick her up Claire
doesn't want to ride with a stranger but
since she's getting late for school she
hops in unfortunately along the way the
creep Desmond starts hitting on her he
asserts that she is the most beautiful
girl that he has ever come across he
even tries asking for her number but
gets ignored after a while they reach
her place and Claire immediately gets
out of the vehicle she then enters her
house and locks the door hoping that the
creep will go away five minutes later
Claire nervously peeks outside and
notices him leaving however when she
turns back she is shocked to see the
back door open the very next second
Desmond approaches her from behind and
knocks her out he then punches her a few
times and drags her to the Bay basement
Claire screams for Mercy but it seems as
if her death is imminent this is why you
never trust a stranger in a truck and
you definitely don't trust a guy named
Duke Desmond surprisingly in the next
scene she is back at the department
store right before her shift is about to
end turns out that Claire dozed off at
work and everything she saw was just a
bad nightmare after leaving the store
she waits at the same spot as earlier
and this time her boyfriend Jimmy shows
up Claire is elated to see him and along
the way she shares everything about how
she was brutally finished off in her
nightmare however Jimmy doesn't pay much
attention to her story and changes the
topic after a while he drops Claire off
to her school and waits outside then in
the evening both of them go to a
secluded spot and start making out
surprisingly while they're at it a drop
of blood falls on Claire's face out of
nowhere she requests that Jimmy check
out the area but the latter doesn't find
anything it seems like Claire is still
shaken by the nightmare she had earlier
later at home she decides to take a cold
bath to relieve her stress however every
time Claire closes her eyes she has
flashes of her nightmare the same creep
Desmond is dragging her to the basement
and finishing her off brutally as Claire
is lost in her thoughts someone slightly
opens the bathroom door this startles
her and she quickly gets up to inspect
after a while she hears a noise coming
from the basement and slowly heads there
the room is all dark so Claire reaches
for the light bulb surprisingly when she
turns on the light she finds her mother
staring into nothingness it's almost as
if the woman has become possessed on
being asked she claims that she is
looking for something Claire is
obviously confused by the encounter but
nonetheless she doesn't ask anything
else and heads upstairs the next day
Claire tries to forget her Nightmares by
spending time with Jimmy and her friends
they play basketball and hang out for
hours in the evening as Jimmy is driving
her back home Claire spots a man burying
something in an open field but even this
time she doesn't think much of it the
next few days Claire doesn't experience
any nightmares or weird incidents
prompting her to believe that she is
fully recovered however ever one evening
while taking a shower she starts seeing
things something tells me she should
just stop being hygienic that would
solve everything at first she notices
someone moving behind the curtain and
then sees the reflection of a man in the
mirror to make matters more creepy she
even has visions of Desmond running away
from a bunch of policemen in the woods
it is evident that something really
spooky is going on that night while
Claire is at her workplace she becomes
bored due to the lack of customers and
decides to take a quick nap once again
she experiences the same vision from
earlier after running for a while
Desmond reaches a cabin in the middle of
the woods and picks up a pistol
seemingly to defend himself against the
coughs however when he turns around he
finds the chief detective Miller waiting
for him with a rifle the vision abruptly
comes to an end when Claire wakes up
confused and scared as she is trying to
make sense of what is happening someone
suddenly enters the store and the lurks
behind a stall terrified Claire sends an
alert to 9-1-1 and grabs a metal bar to
confront the Intruder she then slowly
makes her way to the stall but
unbeknownst to her Desmond has already
creeped up behind her in the blink of an
eye he attacks her and starts choking
her unwilling to give up Claire gouges
his eyes with every ounce of her
strength until he starts bleeding
profusely however despite this Desmond
appears to be unfazed he still hasn't
loosened his grip on her he continues
choking her but at the last moment he
lets go saying not yet yes yet boot his
ass Claire God damn after Desmond leaves
the police along with the same detective
from her vision Miller arrives at the
scene and takes Claire away at the
police station detective Miller
interrogates her about what happened but
every time she tries to explain that an
intruder tried to kill her the other
policeman in the room start chuckling
this is when detective Miller brings out
a monitor and shows her the CCTV footage
from the incident shockingly it turns
out that Claire was merely hallucinating
and fighting with herself there was no
intrusion and not even a drop of blood
was found in the store despite all the
evidence Claire is still certain that
she was attacked by Desmond she claims
that she felt excruciating pain while
being choked by the Intruder however to
her shock detective Miller reveals that
he actually shot and killed Desmond a
week ago the creep had apparently
abducted and murdered two teenagers
taken aback by the Revelation Claire
finally accepts the possibility that she
has gone insane seeing her in this
miserable State detective Miller decides
to escort her home but unfortunately
along the way she once again falls
asleep this time she sees her boyfriend
Jimmy fixing a car at first glance it
appears to be a good dream cause Jimmy's
laying that sweet pipe but after a few
minutes Desmond arrives in bludgeon's
Jimmy with an ax in the next scene
Claire wakes up in the car but there is
no sign of detective Miller or the other
cops she has somehow reached the same
open field where she witnessed a man
burying something as she tries to
comprehend the situation Desmond arrives
with a corpse possibly Jimmy's and loads
it into the trunk Claire screams in
horror but she can do nothing when
Desmond gets seated next to her and
starts driving soon he drops her off at
home and tries to comfort her Claire
keeps on saying that this is not real
but Desmond makes her understand that
the only real thing in the world is what
she feels saying this he takes her
inside the house incapacitates her and
then drags her to the basement just like
before Desmond then takes out a sharp
knife and rips off Claire's rips off
Claire's face later she again wakes up
in the department store which implies
that the whole thing is in a loop she
leaves the store she reaches home she is
killed by Desmond repeat hence this time
she decides to break the loop by doing
something different Claire doesn't wait
for her boyfriend at their usual spot
and instead proceeds to walk home on the
way she comes across the same open field
and also spots Desmond however before he
can see her she hides behind a tree
later while Claire is in class she falls
asleep and has another nightmare
seriously Claire just drink some coffee
or something she sees Desmond
approaching a bloody to Jimmy and
finishing him off for good after a while
she wakes up from her Nightmare and
immediately heads out Jimmy has come
them to take her home and he tries to
ask what is wrong but Claire doesn't say
anything however when he keeps on
insisting Claire reveals that she has
been seeing things she has visions of a
man named Desmond who finds her no
matter where she goes and kills her
brutally in one of her Visions he even
killed Jimmy it's almost as if they are
trapped in an endless loop at first
Jimmy laughs at her story claiming that
it is BS but when Claire becomes angry
and threatens to walk away he decides to
help her later the two head to the local
church and meet a pastor on explaining
everything the pastor tells the couple
not to worry as Desmond is already dead
even if his Spirit looms he cannot harm
them because he is in Hell however
Claire is still not convinced so she
decides to visit Desmond's abandoned
house and look for Clues a while later
the couple reaches the place which
happens to be in the middle of nowhere
it is a small eerie looking house with a
few rooms in it yep sounds like a house
while Claire heads inside one of the
rooms to inspect Jimmy heads upstairs to
take a dump unfortunately Desmond who is
revealed to be alive arrives at the
scene he notices someone in his restroom
and immediately heads upstairs with a
gun Ain't No one gonna dump him up twice
the next second a gunshot is heard which
sends shivers down Claire's spine
Desmond has again killed Jimmy he then
loads the corpse in his car's trunk and
leaves after a while a terrified Claire
comes out of the house and keeps running
until she reaches her school then she
heads to the library and starts
researching Desmond and his past
shockingly one of the news articles
mentions that Claire and Jimmy were
abducted a month back Jimmy's corpse was
found near a field but Claire is still
missing however due to the circumstances
surrounding her disappearance everyone
has assumed her to be dead desperate for
answers Claire runs out of the library
and heads straight to the open field
where she saw a man possibly Desmond
burying something she reaches the exact
spot and starts Excavating the ground lo
and behold she finds her own torn face
there revealing that she is actually
dead in real life at the same time
Desmond also arrives there in his car so
Claire makes a run for it after hours of
running she reaches her best friend
Tina's house and explains everything to
her being the good friend that she is
Tina calms her down and asks her to take
rest in the other room while she calls
the police Claire obliges but as she
waits for help to arrive she passes out
due to exhaustion as expected she has a
nightmare detective Miller and Desmond
are having a standoff where the latter
tries to claim his innocence he says
that someone has implanted a chip inside
his brain and because of it he was
forced to kill the two teenagers however
detective Miller is having none of it
and he shoots the murderer to death when
Claire wakes up she hears her friend
Tina talking to someone it isn't a cop
and she appears to be saying he is
catching on he will soon get used to it
out of curiosity Claire peeks through
the corridor and notices that the man is
none other than the killer Desmond once
again he has arrived to finish her off
fortunately Claire quickly locks herself
inside a room and manages to escape
through the window she then gets into
Desmond's car and drives off narrowly
avoiding him on the way after a while
she reaches home and desperately
searches for her mother but doesn't find
her just then she hears someone
screaming from the basement it is her
mother who is calling for help Claire
knows that she will never return if she
Ventures into the basement but hearing
her mother's desperate cries for help
she decides to risk it all surprisingly
when she approaches her mother the
latter grabs her and says don't you get
it you have to really you have to relive
what you did Claire doesn't understand
what's going on and desperately tries to
run away but at the same time Desmond
also arrives this means that the only
person she trusts in the world her
mother has also betrayed her but
strangely the lady tells Claire to stop
calling her mother and keeps on
addressing her as a male at last she
calls her a murderer for killing her
daughter here it is finally revealed
that the Claire that we have been seeing
since the start of the movie is actually
Desmond he is in Hell paying the price
for his sins the world he has been
living in is just a fabrication and the
Desmond that is after him is actually
Satan what because of the heinous crimes
he committed in his life he has been
sentenced to an infinite number of
brutal deaths at the hand of his real
self moreover Desmond has been given the
identity of Claire so that he can feel
and experience how scared and helpless
she was when he killed her this Loop
will keep on going until eternity and no
matter how much he tries to run or hide
he will always be found and killed jokes
on you Satan Psychopaths don't feel
anything after the revelation we see
Desmond in his original Self being
carved open by Satan the movie ends as
Claire AKA Desmond again wakes up in the
department store ready to start the
doomed cycle once again subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching